التصعيد في اليمن الى اهله سؤال عريض صاحب
الاتفاق السعوديه الايراني الذي اعلن
بوساطه صينيه في الحادي عشر من مارس الجري
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بالفرحان جدد بالامس الدعوه لبدء العمليات
السياسيه بين الحكومه اليمنيه والحوثي
مكشفت صحيفه وول ستريت جورنال عن موافقه
ايران على وقف تسليح الخوطيين في اطار
الاتفاق على استئناف العلاقات مع السعوديه
مشيره ايضا الى ان نهجه ايران حيال الصراع
في اليمن سيكون اختبارا حقيقيا لنواياها
بعد عوده العلاقات مع الرياض
ضم الينا من لندن الكاتب الصحفي في جريده
الشرق الاوسط بدر القحطاني حياك الله بدر
معي في نشره الرابعه
يعني عندما تقول
حسب مسؤولين امريكيين والسعوديين ايران
وافقت على وقف ارسال شحنات الاسلحه الى
حلفائها الحوثيين في اليمن كجزء من الصفقه
ربما يعني هل يعني ذلك اولا ان ايران
اعترفت بالفعل بانها هي من تقوم بامداد
الحوثيين بالاسلحه وهو الامر الذي كانت
تنكره مرارا يعني في السابق هل ستتوقف
فعلا عن ذلك هل يعتبر ذلك ايضا موقفا
متقدما من ايران في تعاملها مع الميليشيات
اليوم
بكل تاكيد مساء الخير عليك وعلى ساده
المشاهدين اعتقد ان الايران في الجولات
الاولى في المحادثات التي عقدت سواء في
بغداد او غيرها من العواصم والمدن مع
السعوديه كانت في البدايه تنكر مساله
الاسلحه ونحن جميعا نعرف ان الاسلحه لا
يتم زرعها ولا يتم
ايجادها من تحت الارض يتم تهريبها الى
داخل اليمن عن طريق البحر او البر وفقا
لتقارير الدوليه وابرزها تقرير خبراء
بمجلس الامن مساله ان ان الملف اليمني
سيكون هو الاختبار وبالفعل اختبار حقيقي
وملموس واختبار افعال لا اقوال الاقوال
الايرانيه بعد الاتفاق ايجابيا وبمجرد
التزامه بمساله عدم تصريح الحوثيين كما
تفضلت هو اعتراف مبدئي وهذا خطوه وهذه
خطوه متقدمه بقيت الكره الان في ملعب
الحوثيين الذين حتى داعميهم الايرانيين
بدون حل الازمه اليمنيه على الاقل وفقا
للروايه الرسميه الايرانيه اعتقد ان
الحوثيين حتى الان لم يصرحوا بموقفهم تجاه
بشكل يعني واضح محمد عبد السلام المتحدث
باسم جماعه انصار
الحوثيين طبعا علق في تغريده على تويتر
دون ذكر الاتفاق بشكل صريح بان المنطقه
بحاجه لعوده العلاقات الطبيعيه بين الدوله
يزيد ذلك من غموض موقف هذه الميليشيات
تجاهها الاتفاق الا يمكن اعتباره ايضا
جزءا من تبادل الادوار بين ايران
والمليشيا الحوثيه في المنطقه
اعتقد هناك حتى لا ننسى هناك وساطه تجريها
السعوديه بمشاركه عمانيه مع الحوثيين وانا
وكثير من المراقبين معي يؤمنون تماما
بقدره السعوديه على اقناع الحوثيين على
مساله الهدنه وعلى مساله
البدء في المفاوضات السياسيه وايضا البنود
التي تتضمنها الهدنه الامميه الاخيره التي
رفضها الحوثيون في اكتوبر الماضي كنا في
نهايه العام تحدثنا عن ابواب السعوديه
واقفال ايران في الازمه اليمنيه فتحت
السعوديه ابواب عديده الحل هذه الازمه من
ضمنها الحوار مع ايران والان توج هذا
الحوار وايران هي التي ساعدت اليه في
البدايه بالمناسبه
بالاتفاقيه الاخيره والتي ما زالت قيداء
الاختبار والامتحان هناك ابواب اخرى عديده
فتحتها السعوديه مثل الوساطه بين الحوثيين
والحكومه اليمنيه بمشاركه عمانيه هناك
ايضا دعم المسار الام خصوصا المبعوث
الاممي الى اليمن هانز جراند بيرج وجهوده
في مختلف الملفات ومن ضمنها الحوار الذي
يحصل هذه الايام في جنيف فيما يتعلق في
ملف الاسرى والمعتقلين هناك كما تفضل وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي الاسبق هناك توازن
استراتيجي تقوده السعوديه في المنطقه
والكل يعلم ان سياسه السعوديه دائما سياسه
دائما تنمويه
واعتقد ان هذا الزخم السعودي هذه المره
راينا زخم الامريكي لمده عامين لم ينجح في
اليمن اعتقد ان الزخم السعودي وزخم
الخليجي في اليمن سوف يكلل بالنجاح اذا ما
اراد اليمنيون انفسهم سواء الحوثيين او
الحكومه اليمنيه التي ابدت بالمناسبه انها
تراقب
الافعال الايرانيه وليس الاقوال الايرانيه
بحذر فهذا الكثير ايضا تحيط بالموضوع لانه
شكوك ما تزال يعني يعني حول موقف ايران من
الحوثيين من ميليشياتها في المنطقه بشكل
عام
قلت بانه جنيف مثلا ما يحدث فيها اليوم هو
ليس مجرد صدفه لابد بانه نتيجه للاثار او
اثار اوليه الاتفاق بين السعوديه وايران
برعايه صيني الى اي مدى يمكن ان يتقدم هذا
الملف والاسئله الاخرى المتعلقه عن موضوع
كذلك مصير الاسلحه اصلا الموجوده بيد
الحوثيين من صواريخ من طائرات مسيره
ايرانيه الصنع تهدد بها ممرات الدوليه
البحريه وغيرها من الامور يعني خلال فتره
الماضي
واذا كان هناك عزيزي خالد شيء تعلمناه في
الازمه اليمنيه فهو نتفائل ولكن الا نفرض
في
المشكله ايضا اذا حتى لو كان القيادات
خصوصا على مستوى مثلا الحوثيين هم ليسوا
حزبا سياسيا وليس لديهم ذلك التنظيم القوي
مجرد يعني مجموعه وهناك
قيادات خصوصا من حزب الله هي التي تقود
مساله الشؤون السياسيه والاعلاميه وما الى
ذلك فبالتالي حتى لو كانت هناك توجيهات من
القيادات فانعكاسها على الارض لا يكون
سريعا فبالتالي نحن لا نفرض في التفاؤل
ولكن الزخم الموجود يدعو الى التامل
والترقب لان كل خطوه ايجابيه سوف تنعكس
بشكل كبير جدا على 30 مليون يمني يعيشون
كابوس الانقلاب منذ العام 2014 وايضا على
مختلف الصعد الاقتصاديه والتجاريه اليمنيه
هناك حاله من الشلل التجاري والاقتصادي في
المقابل نرى ان هذا النوع من الاجتماعات
نرانا هذا النوع من
الاتفاقات التي او التوازنات التي تقودها
السعوديه في المنطقه سيصب بالخير على
اليمن واليمنيين ولكن هذا لن يثمر شيئا
اذا لم
يتنازل الحوثيين اذا لم يقدموا انفسهم
جماعه سياسيه تجلس في طاوله مفاوضات
وتحافظ على بعض المكاسب التي حصلت عليها
وايضا الحكومه اليمنيه قدمت الكثير من
التنازلات
واعتقد انه يطلب منهم المزيد حتى حقنا
للدماء وتحقيقا لانهاء هذه الازمنه لا
تنسى الازمه اليمنيه اذا انتهت هناك هل هل
الوقائم ينتظر هل الوقت الان يعني هو
وقت مناسب خاصه وان الكثير اليوم يرون بان
ايران لا يمكن ان تتخلى عن حلفائها
وميليشياتها وفقا اصلا مبدا اساسي في
دستورها يعني موجود وينص عليه ومبني عليه
هذا نظاميه تراهن على الوقت ربما تحاول ان
تغير في تكتيكات هذه المعركه تهدئ خاصه
انها تتدرب فبالتالي الطرف الاخر وهنا
يتحدث عن السعوديه وعن الصين
هل هناك ادراك لذلك بمعنى ان هناك وقت
واضح وصريح يجب ان تحسم فيه بعض الملفات
للتقدم خطوه نحو ملفات اعمق واكبر
نحن عندما نقرا القراءات التي
تخرج من وكالات الانباء العالميه ومن
مراكز التفكير هناك حديث عن ان ايران
اصبحت في ورطه ورطه داخليه ورطه مع
الاوروبيين ورطه مع المجتمع الدولي ورطه
مع الجيران فبالتالي حتى ولو كان هذا
الموضوع مرحله بالنسبه الى ايران لا بد من
اعطائه فرصه لماذا لان اذا كان هناك دوله
تقود السلام والتنميه فلابد ان يتذوق
الايرانيون قليلا من هذا
يكون هناك نموذج للقياده الايرانيه لان
ترى كيف تكون الثمار حسن الجوار وكيف تكون
ثمار العلاقات الجيده الخلافات ستكون
موجوده ولا تنتهي ونعتقد انها ستصل حتى
الى مرحله التحالفات وفقا للتسريبات
الاخيره لكن مساله التعايش ومساله
ضروره الظروف الحاليه قد تكون ربما وقتيه
ولكنها تمه لحاله افضل بكثير من حاله
الاستعداد التام حاله حتى الفجر في
الخصومه مساله ان ايران في ورطه هذه لا
غبار عليها نرى الداخل الايراني مشتعرا
نرى ايران في اتفاق النووي المعطله نرى ان
هناك ضغوط غربيه عليها فيما يتعلق سواء
بحقوق الانسان فيما يتعلق بكثير من
الملفات اضف الى ذلك كله حرمانها من 30
مليار دولار امريكي شهريا
من تصدير النفط فهذه الضغوطات كلها تجعل
النظام وربما السجالات الداخليه في النظام
هي التي سوف تعرقله ما لم يكن ويعتقد انها
ستجد كل الخير اذا احسنت والتزمت بالشروط
التي شكرا بها في بكين شكرا جزيلا من لندن
الكاتب الصحفي في جريده الشرق الاوسط بدر
القحطاني